Hallo herzlich willkommen hier ist ukw unsere kleine welt ich bin tim und nachdem wir letztes mal den blick ganz weit nach asien geschoben haben und uns mal die situation in hongkong angeschaut haben.
Geht's jetzt wieder mal zurück aufs homeland hier ich begrüße den john john worst hallo.
Hallo.
Mittlerweile ist glaube ich genug zeit vergangen um den emotionalen schock der die letzten monate wahrscheinlich ausgelöst haben so ein wenig zu verkraften
der brexit day ist gekommen und auch schon wieder vergangen und ja nun ist leider das eingetreten,
was lange lange zeit ein wenig in der luft hängen sich allerdings als wir hier das letzte mal gesprochen haben schon ein wenig abgezeichnet hat weil die situation war einfach bekloppt spätestens mit der entscheidung neuwahlen durchzuführen,
war es einfach schon sehr wahrscheinlich dass die situation kippt.
Wir haben ja das letztes mal auch schon so ein bisschen angesprochen aber vielleicht nochmal wert da emotional auch an an dieser stelle nochmal so anzudocken verkrafte irgendwie immer noch nicht so richtig diesen.
Diese situation dass die opposition sich in diese neuwahlen hat so ziehen lassen.
Ja das stimmt aber grob.
Wenn wir blicken zurück das war so eine fehlentscheidung so ein eine unterhaus wahl so zustimmen.
Aber wenn wir blicken ja zurück die die verhältnisse zwischen labor und die liberalen.
Waren schon seit monaten so problematisch dass was für anderen optionen.
Gäbe es damals.
Weil jeremy corbyn hat so gesagt ja ich ich wäre für eine so eine art übergangsregierung.
Aber nur wenn ich selbst der premierminister bin in so eine übergangsregierung.
Das hat die damalige vorsitzende der der der liberalen joeys winsor abgelehnt die standen bei zwanzig prozent in den meinungsumfragen die liberalen so sagen wir so oktober november
ja wir haben dann auch gute aussichten gut zu punkten bei bayern unterhaus wahlen und.
Weil die liberalen worten eine ehemalige konservative wähler für sich gewinnen so eine kompromiss oder oder auch so temporär eine unterstützung für kurven aus premierminister.
Wäre für die für die liberalen unmöglich damals also die beiden haben so gedacht okay
corbyn auf eine seite für eine auswahl stattfindet ich kann wiederholen was ich gemacht habe schon in zwanzig siebzehn also ich könnte so an und der auswahl dann gewinnt eine schlechte ausgangslage in die meinungsumfragen und bei den liberalen war es mehr oder weniger englisch also das bedeutet,
ich war auch dann selbst so okay lass uns mal dieses und hauswald an machen weil sonst kriegen wir dann.
Die chancen sind höher dass wir kriegen dann ein brexit also das ist zumindest dann eine chance lass uns mal auch dann mittel so zu sogenannten tactical voting zu versuchen das das beste aus eine schlechte situation zu machen.
Wir.
Probieren das halt und themas wir zumindest mal gesprochen haben dass wir so mehr oder weniger am beginn der wahlkampf damals was du dann gesehen haben ist laber hat eine sehr schwache wahlkampf,
und auch geführt und auch einige taktiker fehlern gemacht die liberalen.
Diese diese idee dass am am beginn der wahlkampf
vincent so gesagt jones winsons die nächste mögliche premierministerin er soll es gegen berg runter für die liberalen in den in den meinungsumfragen während dieses ganze ein ganzes wahlkampf.
Also es ging dann für die für die beiden oppositionsparteien dann einfach schlecht aber grobe am am am beginn dieses wahlkampf.
Was sonst,
wäre damals möglich ende oktober anfang november also ich sah das damals aus dem einzigen möglichen obwohl man muss auch sagen gefährliches weg,
aus der damalige situation,
und das war auch kein rasantes wahlsieg für boris johnson also der hat unter dreiundvierzig prozent der abgegebenen stimmen gekriegt
und es ist wegen dem frischen wahlsystem dass das verfügt jetzt über eine mehrheit vom von nachsicht sitzen also man könnte dann mal sagen.
Die oppositionsparteien besonders laber haben dieses wahlkampf verloren es war nicht unbedingt dass boris johnson.
Dieses war so gewonnen hatte der hat kaum an stimmen gewonnen gegenüber diese katastrophales wahlkampf von von von von theresa may zwanzig siebzehn da wenig gewonnen es ist das labels,
unterstützung deutlich zurückgegangen.
Du hast dich ja dann auch noch selber extrem eingeklinkt und hast so eine eine eine eine unfassbare zahl an kleinen videoclips aufgenommen.
Genau ja.
Wenn ich es richtig sehe also quasi so jeden nahezu jedem wahlkreis wieviel gibt's überhaupt insgesamt.
Es gibt sechshundertfünfzig wahlkreisen ich habe etwa hundertsiebzig videos gefilmt ich hoffe für alle wahlkreisen die mehr oder weniger,
so an der grenze waren zwischen,
laber oder die konservativen gewinnen könnten habe ich dann dann diverse videos gefilmt ich habe eine twitter follower so gefragt okay
mach ich dann einige videos für anderen wahlkreisen wo meine follower ist auch dann dann wohnen.
Also es war dann einfach mal so sein ok wenn man als auch so,
aussicht in einem bestimmten wahlkreis wohnt für welche partei muss man dann wählen um die konservativen zu stoppen.
Also das war dem sinn von diese diese ganze videos es war einfach natürlich sehr problematisch das sind viele wahlkreisen die konservativen.
Hatten keine mehrheit der abgegebenen stimmen gekriegt sondern mehr als den zweitplatzierten
und unsere versuch war dann einfach mal so sein okay label ist auf dem zweiten platz also bitte hier laber statt die liberalen zu wählen
oder dann umgekehrt um einfach dann diese mehrheit für die für die die konservativen zu verhindern,
es war natürlich problematisch weil viele pro-europäer haben sie gesagt hey moment also wir wollen jeremy corbyn nicht unterstützen weil der ist für uns nicht pro-europäisch genug weil er so eine
etwas neutrale position im in sachen brexit die labor position war wir sind offiziell noch für einen austritt
wir wollen einen besseren deal mit brüssel verhandeln aber dann wir wollen ein zweites referendum organisieren also das war für mich.
Ausreichend um dann labels unterstützen aber für viele pro-europäer war es einfach nicht ausreichend und wir haben dann bei dieser unterhaus wahlkampf,
in vielen wahlkreisen zum beispiel kensington city westminster in london wimbledon sogar auch da gab es drei parteien die dann sehr hart gekämpft haben und in alle drei haben die konservativen gewonnen also diese pro-europäische wählerschaft
war zwischen liberalen und laber so geteilt und an die konservativen haben dann beide überholt und dann diese wahlkreisen dann gewonnen.
Wenn man sieht hat diese so taktisches voting voting überhaupt funktioniert wenn man schaut in den zahlen,
das hat zwischen zwölf und zwanzig wahlkreis und für label gerettet und.
Vielleicht weil die diversen aktivisten könnten einige wahlkreisen nicht so genau prognostizieren besonders kensington zum beispiel,
vielleicht ein oder zweifel label sogar verloren weil die unsere positionierung waren ja einige wahlkreise nicht klar aber grob diese versuche leute zu sein ok wenn ihr wollt die konservativen stoppen das hat,
verluste von zwölf bis zwanzig sitzen für labour verhindert also es könnte deutlich schlechter sein für laber assist,
sogar ausgegangen ist zum beispiel wo meine wo meine eltern wohnen ein wahlkreis in süd newport west gewonnen
für labour mit nur achthundert stimmen vorsprung vor dem vor dem konservativen
und da hat die kandidatin für labour sogar die pro-europäer so diese europe wo mein vater im im im im im vorstand ist
so eine ein nettes brief nach dem wahr geschickt vielen dank für diese für die unterstützung oder für diese dieses rad voting zu verwenden wir denken dass das dieses wahlkreis für uns laber so gerettet,
das reicht natürlich nicht weil besonders in viele norden englische wahlkreisen diese sogenannten wall ist gefallen also das sind viele.
Industrie städte oder extra bergwerk gestellt wo es in städten mit mit vorher gab's stahlindustrie.
Die sind die die die arten von wahlkreisen die vorher laber gewählt haben und diesmal dann für die haben jetzt konservative abgeordneten.
So ein bisschen wie das ruhrgebiet in deutschland.
Ja genau aber es ist auch sehr interessant zu beobachten wo ich selbst noch als auslands wähle wähle ist im besten green bond im osten da ist labels anteil an abgegebene stimmen sogar.
Mit zwei prozentpunkten höher diesmal als in zwanzig siebzehn also in städten wo es eine junge wählerschaft gibt,
oder wo es viele leute mit universitätsabschluss oder wo es viele ähnliche minderheiten gibt,
da war es noch okay für laber aber das problem ist es gibt einfach nicht genug wahlkreisen wo diese arten von menschen in eine mehrheit sind.
Traditionelle laber wähler die über fünfzig jahre alt sind die kein universitätsabschluss haben oder wohnen in städten wo es keine universität gibt,
die arten von wähler die dann von leiber zu den konservativen gewechselt sind oder einfach zu hause geblieben sind also.
Wahlbeteiligung war unter ein prozent höher als in zwanzig siebzehn,
also das bedeutet viele leute haben eine warte dann ich könnte deutlich höher sein weil niemand mochte boris johnson so so richtig also eine deutlich höhere wahlbeteiligung haben viele leute so gehofft.
Aber das das kam nicht zustande.
Falls ihr alle jeremy corbyn nicht leiden konnten.
Viele schon ja das stimmt also und es klingt ein bisschen ungewöhnlich aber.
Bemerkt so eine woche vor der vor der wahl dass dieses wahlkampf ging echt schief der damalige.
Sky news korrespondent der ist mittlerweile gewechselt aber damals war noch was kleines.
Der ist so ein working mum club in birmingham gegangen so eine so eine art social club für.
Arbeiter oder ehemaliger arbeit und da hat dann diesen sie die sind so traditionelle laber wlan und
und da hat mir der journalist mit diesem die diese männer hauptsächlich männer gesprochen und einfach mal so ja und die haben alle gesagt wir wir wählen diesmal konservativen nicht mehr label wieso wieso das denn
jeremy corbyn,
haben die so gesagt also der war mehr auf der seite der der der der nationalisten in irland,
statt die junior nisten in der achtziger,
es war irgendwie der war gegen uns also gegen unsere armee damals in der achtziger,
das ist ein unsinn also das war die dreißig vierzig jahre her also wieso spielt das dann eine rolle in dieses wahlkampf ja der war irgendwie gegen.
Irgendwie ergänzt aber irgendwie.
Willst du das denn das ist ein schwachsinn ja also wenn irgendwas wichtig ist in sachen nun eland ja das ist was ist im einfluss von brexit auf nordirland,
kaum debattiert werden dieses wahlkampf aber seit jahren in den in den in den zeitungen ja jeremy corbyn politik ist deswegen kann man ihm mischt als premierminister dann werden.
Also moment mal also das kann nicht sein dass leute motivieren dass oder haben diese motivation dass sie kamen können laber nicht mehr unterstützen wegen etwas wasser was jeremy corbyn gesagt hat in der achtziger
und aus meiner sicht nicht mehr relevant ist aber das waren für diese männer in birmingham super wichtig in der achtziger jahren stand er auf der falschen seite.
Also das kam irgendwie bei den menschen gut an so scheiße an weil dieses kritikern corbyn hauptsächlich in den konservativen zeitungen der war kein der stand nicht auf der seite von unsere soldaten,
irgendwie also.
Dass das seid inwiefern dieses wahlkampf von der realität oder von den jetzigen realität abgekoppelt war.
Wie das ganze brexit-votum an sich auch so also ich hatte auch so ein bisschen den eindruck am schluss so okay man.
Man kann da viel rational darüber nachdenken aber diese rationalität hatte einfach irgendwie immer noch keine chance man,
hat so richtig den eindruck gehabt so selbst wenn das land schon teilweise verstanden hat dass sie sich da eigentlich schwer die scheiße geritten haben jetzt müssen sie auch wirklich komplett darin versinken.
Das alles andere gibt der stolz gar nicht mehr her so und dann dann verfangen natürlich auch solche nationalistischen talking points die fast schon für mich so ein bisschen wie ausreden klingen.
Ich stehe hier zu.
So ja aber er hat irgendwie das falsche tweet pattern angehabt so vollkommen irrelevant ja.
Ja dann kam es zur wahl jetzt hat halt,
boris johnson einerseits nicht nur diese achtzig sitze mehrheit im parlament sondern was ja auch noch mit einher gegangen ist ist ja auch eine,
eine.
So eine ein komplettes austauschen der abgeordneten selber also sind ja auch extrem viel moderate lang verdiente konservative gar nicht erst aufgestellt worden weil das ja eine,
eine möglichkeit ist der partei dass eben sozusagen zu bestimmen weil es nicht unbedingt immer so von unten gewählt wird wie man es hier kennt.
Das heißt man hat jetzt nicht nur so mit einer übermacht zu tun soll man hat's auch noch mit einer übermacht von leuten zu tun die eigentlich alle nur auf dem ticket sind weil sie bereit sind einfach diese diese diesen brexit kurs von boris johnson zu unterstützen.
Man muss auch sagen dass es gab so ein deal parteiintern es gab so grob,
drei gruppen ja wie du gerade gesagt hast die pragmatisierten um um,
und die sind einfach so alle raus dann sind so zwei gruppen,
übrig geblieben die die wollten ein brexit mit seinem deal und die die worten ein brexit ohne deal also möglichst schnell raus
gab es dann ein deal zwischen diesen beiden gruppen ja wir wollen ein brexit mit einem deal
und das unbedingt bis ende zwanzig zwanzig also keine verlängerung in der übergangsphase wurde
und das war dann den weg die konservativen zu vereinigen also
eine gruppe raus um die liebe von den zwei übrigen guten kompromiss ist ja mit einem deal aber dann möglichst schnell und das ist wie wir dann den punkt erreicht haben dass wir sind jetzt in dieser phase dass großbritannien,
dann rasch
ein ein austritt so eine komplette austrittsloch lösung bis ende dieses jahr und dann das ist der fahrer an den weg für boris johnson die komplette konservative partei
hinter ihm dann zu vereinigen aber wir haben schon in den letzten wochen schon einige kleinen spannungen schon gesehen also vielleicht ist es.
Noch ein tick schwieriger als johnson dachte.
Bleiben vielleicht nochmal beim wahl.
Ergebnis also labor und vor allem auch die liberaldemokraten also dass deren ergebnis war ja nochmal doppelt schlimm weil ja unter anderem auch die chefin des jos winston
nicht mehr im parlament vertreten ist weil sie ihren sitz verloren hat das bedeutet dann quasi auch dass sie die parteiführung.
Ja ja.
Verliert damit.
Ja genau genau ja also es gibt jetzt so einen parteiinterne urwahl auch bei den liberalen gerade.
Also komplett zerstörung ähnlich sieht es bei labor aus weil kommen dann doch irgendwie ein bisschen zumindest eingesehen hat dass es mit ihm nicht mehr so geht technisch ist ja noch der führer und es gibt jetzt glaub ich vier oder fünf potenzielle kandidaten.
Es bleiben nur noch drei ja und es wird bekannt gegeben anfang april wer dann jeremy corbyn an der parteivorsitz ersetzt.
Was heißt es wird bekannt gegeben also wie wird denn abgestimmt darüber.
So die mitglieder und mitglieder von,
organisationen die so den labour familie zugehören so darunter gewerkschaften haben dann das das stimmrecht aber die mitglieder von von,
so wie man im englischen affiliate organisations haben auch das stimmrecht also es ist so eine so eine richtige uhr war aber nicht nur parteimitglieder dürfen dann da mitstimmen.
Da gibt's ja kurz dazu ein bisschen hoffnung weil unter die drei kandidatinnen die im rennen sind man hat.
Cheers dame der überragende favorite so der brexit spreche der der labour partei.
Der ist unter den drei kandidatinnen die grobe der pragmatiker grob.
Das ist relativ längst aber nicht so weit nach links wie jeremy corbyn oder oder die leute um corbyn,
dann gibt's bailey oder wie die journalisten long bailey benennen rebecca daily.
Sie ist so ein bisschen die die so kontinuität copien kandidatin also will eine rolle für jeremy corbyn in seinem team behalten also es beliebt auf die,
linke flügel der partei.
Und dann es gibt auch dann dazu bekannt dass sie aus ist also es ist halt ein verbindung so die diese
arbeite schicht die vorher für label gestimmt haben also gesagt das label wollte ein zweites referendum organisieren das war den falschen weg also lieber ein brett das label musste brexit dann
unbedingt ausführen also.
Irgendwie die chancen sind dann sozusagen sehen sehr gut aus das star man gewinnt der ist ein ehemaliger jurist der ist ein ehemaliger chef staatsanwalt in großbritannien.
Ist ein sehr kluger typ sehr intelligent hat gute mitarbeiter kann gut reden.
Ist nicht super charismatisch ja also ist nicht so dramatisch wie zum beispiel aber ich bin sicher das label könnte eine super gute und effiziente opposition,
bilden unter star wenn er dann gewinnt also das bedeutet dass dann labels chancen könnten dann.
Ein bisschen besser dann aussehen wenn er dann gewinnt aber zu zeit weil laber kümmert sich um,
dieses urwahl um auf jeremy corbyns nachfolger das bedeutet es gibt zur zeit faktisch keine opposition in ingo in großbritannien gerade also das macht dann das arbeit für für johnson in sachen brexit dann,
relativ einfach ja aber das bedeutet dass aus meiner sicht es könnte dann mittelfristig ein bisschen besser für leber gehen.
Die anderen gewinner wenn man so will sind gottes national party die wiederum recht gut abgeschnitten haben ich habe jetzt gerade das wahlergebnis nicht ganz im kopf aber sie hatten ja bei der vor,
vorletzten wahl nahezu alle sitze in denen sie angetreten sind gewonnen dann bei der vorletzten wahl.
Ein paar davon wieder eingebüßt jetzt haben sie wieder was zurückgewonnen werden auch nicht ganz so massiv was heißt denn das für die fdp.
Ja also ist ja schwierig weil.
Die will natürlich ein zweites unabhängigkeitsreferendum in schottland organisieren.
Ist besonders wichtig für die show
jetzt gerade weil das argument gegen einen unabhängigen schottland damals in zwanzig vierzehn war ja bleib mal in großbritannien weil das ist den weg in die eu zu bleiben also großbritannien ist jetzt aus der eu also den weg dann für ein wieder beitritt schottlands wäre dann zuerst unabhängig zu sein
ein weg zu einem unabhängigen legalen weg es war eine unabhängige dann gibt es ja nicht weil es braucht die zustimmung london so mein zweites referendum zu organisieren
und das hat boris johnson bis jetzt komplett und total abgelehnt.
So ist es dann könnte dann eine schwierige lage werden also könnte man den punkt erreichen wie es wie es in katalonien,
ausgegangen ist wo die dann die leute die für einen unabhängigkeit waren wollten dann einen,
inoffiziellen referendum dann organisieren also den weg will wollen die schottische nationalisten nicht nehmen.
Aber man könnte dann irgendwann mal den punkt erreichen ja okay dann das ist dem einzigen weg.
Ich sehe zurzeit dass die schottische nationalisten spielend dem so langen spiel das.
Unterstützung für einen unabhängigen schottland steigt schrittweise in den letzten meinungsumfragen es ist knapp über fünfzig prozent ich denke die wollen dann eine stabilere vorsprung haben.
Und die wollen dann erneut den schottischen parlaments war gewinnen und das steht nächstes jahr vor saß bedeutet.
Ich bin der meinung dass die spielen dann auf ein ein zweites und ein referendum zwanzigzweiundzwanzig oder dreiundzwanzig
die kommen dann nächstes jahr mit boris johnson sah okay jetzt haben wir einen erneut ein mehrheit an mehrheit der abgegebenen stimmen fahr ich sogar in schottland für die schottische nationalisten also lass uns dann mal ein zweites referendum dann organisieren.
Boris johnson.
Nach wie vor interessiert sich nicht für großbritannien insgesamt sondern interessiert sich für die interessen von seiner eigenen parteimitglieder.
Er hat nicht so viele parteimitglieder in schottland also die schottische partei ist
klein im vergleich zu den mitgliederzahlen insgesamt bei den konservativen und die mitglieder der konservativen sind
mehrheitlich gegen einen unabhängigen schottland obwohl die mögen die schotten ja nicht so besonders ja die da da oben da so dass ein nettes ort wo man so,
oder shooting also ja ja ja den in den sommermonaten.
Also das bedeutet er ist gegen einen unabhängigen schottland mehr umso.
Ein bisschen böse zu den zu den schottische nationalisten zu sein weil das ist die populäre lösung und die parteimitglieder der konservativen also aus meiner sicht mittelfristig diese position.
Ich kann nicht einfach so bleiben wenn es so.
Alles riskieren will es wäre aus meiner sicht sinnvoll so ein zweites referendum möglichst bald zu machen aus sicht der konservativen weil wenn man sowas jetzt sagen wir in den nächsten sechs monaten original organisieren,
die chancen dass die die schatten für die unabhängigkeit stimmen sind gering.
Weil die schwersten folgen des brexits sind nicht bekannt und es ist jetzt zur zeit sehr knapp in den meinungsumfragen.
Wenn man warten bis zwanzig zweiundzwanzig oder dreiundzwanzig dann dient die schlechten folgen des brexits sind dann bekannter.
Und zweitens man hat dann die zeit diese so opposition gegenüber london das das
deutlich aufzubauen in in in in adams also das bedeutet
aus meiner sicht war es vielleicht sinnvoll so ein ein zweites referendum möglichst bald zu organisieren aussicht von boris johnson aber das ist nicht in den interessen von den parteimitgliedern so das bedeutet dass ich ich denke dass die chancen dass er da sowas tut sind sehr sehr gering,
aber das ist sogar sicher so meine vermutung also,
erst zweite hälfte nächstes jahr wird richtig krachen weil dann nach dem den schottischen wahl vorgesehen für mein nächstes jahr.
Ich habe noch die schöne verschwörungstheorie gehört das ja boris johnson schottland eigentlich auch total egal sein kann weil letzten endes geht's ihm darum die macht der konservativen zu sichern und wenn dann noch nicht mal mehr schottland mit im boot ist dann wäre das ja in gewisser hinsicht langfristig gesichert.
Ja das stimmt und ja also,
er hat wenig interesse auf alle teile in großbritannien sauser england muss man auch sagen dass auch die konservativen sind auch sehr schwach in wales obwohl es da ist kann er sehr starke unabhängigkeitsbewegung gibt also das bedeutet,
unabhängigen wales wird es ja nicht geben johnson hat null interesse an not ihr land also das haben wir gesehen in was für ein deal dann verhandelt hat,
aber natürlich auch sich von diesen diese idee was eigentlich sehr beliebt ist in konservativen kreisen diese idee dass großbritannien kann mal wieder so ein
welthandel macht werden wenn man verliert zwei von vier teilen großbritanniens und auch ein ein großes teil der tipp der oberfläche also nicht so viel am nur fünf komma fünf millionen menschen wohnen schottland aber ein teil von,
so der oberfläche des landes ist es schon groß das bedeutet aus sicht die von diese so großes großbritannien,
es ist ja natürlich ein verlust wenn man verliert zwei teile des weiteren des landes also ich denke das ist vera boris johnson irgendwie lieber wenn die nicht unabhängig wir werden aber ehrlich wie wie stark ist eine interesse an dann diese frage
ich bin nicht so besonders beeindruckt dass er findet das um besonders wichtig.
Ich meine als wir hier mit dieser serie angefangen haben haben wir uns ja erstmal sehr eigentlich so über die seele dieses landes selber unterhalten,
so und was bedeutet nation und was was was was ist eigentlich so diese identität des landes und
gerade diese ganze brexit prozess hat ja noch mal extrem klar gemacht dass eben sozusagen diese uhr nationalen grenzen auch eine große rolle spielen es geht eigentlich.
Es geht irgendwie die ganze zeit nur um england hat man so den eindruck die ganze argumentation ist immer eine eine englische perspektive,
während man hier in deutschland natürlich immer schnell dabei ist ich versuche da immer sehr akkurat zu sein aber es ist so ein bisschen wie mit holland und niederlande ne man sagt halt england und meint irgendwie alles,
aber die unterschiede sind ja dann schon noch relativ stark und spätestens wenn man mal in schottland war was ich glücklicherweise war merkt man dann auch sehr schnell okay da gibt's schon,
ein grund warum es zwei beziehungsweise insgesamt ja sogar vier fußball nationalmannschaften gibt in diesem.
Ja genau.
Weil weil weil die die unterschiede sind halt mehr als nur in dem only.
Und das ist so ein bisschen das worüber ich mir so gedanken gemacht habe ob ob dieser ganze brexit prozess der ja,
ich denke da sind wir uns einig jetzt mittelfristig traumatische zustände auslösen kann nicht auch dazu führt dass eben einfach auch dieses nationale trennung gefühl noch weiter ausgeprägt ist sowohl in england als eben auch in den anderen gebieten.
Genau das stimmt und auch wenn wenn man sieht die debatte gerade in in schottland unter.
Schotten die proeuropäisch aber gegen einen unabhängigen schottland sind diese menschen haben.
Die sind so verloren in diese komplette debatte also so fern freunde des großen vereinigtes großbritannien und für den brexit.
Das funktioniert ja halbwegs oder
für einen unabhängigen schottland und popo eu das geht auch halbwegs also die sind so zum relativ so stabiler oder oder gruppen die an irgendeine vertretung erhaben in die deutsche debatte,
für.
Also gegen einen unabhängigen schottland und für die eu zu sein ja und es gibt ja eine große gruppe von menschen in schottland die genau diese präzision vertreten,
diese menschen die haben null politische vertretung weder noch in schottland und noch in in in in westminster also
es ist da dann fit für diese diese menschen dann sehr sehr schwierig und und und schau mal auch in also da gibt's,
den beginn von einer richtigen unabhängigkeitsbewegung also wir wollen ja nicht was in london passiert ja gehört man,
ständiger von waliser politiker sich auf facebook gesehen haben ein freund von mir der eine ehemalige labor abgeordnete hat vor ein jahrzehnt nicht sein sitz verloren aber es ist noch soweit ich weiß noch leben mitglied,
ja okay jetzt so meine gute also wie schnell enden sich die meinungen da also einfach mal dieses idee was.
Schon seit ein paar jahrzehnten.
Oder gewarnt popularity schaut an diese idee das london ist oder das london politisches system ist so kaputt dass das einzige weg ist dann unabhängig zu sein,
das sieht man ein bisschen jetzt auch im kader.
Ja also und und boris johnson wie du vor kurzem gesagt hast boris johnson hat null interesse.
Diese spannungen einfach zu reduzieren weil er sagt ja also wir müssen zusammen bleiben weil wir müssen einfach zusammen bleiben
soll das reicht nicht also es gibt es gibt viele leute in schottland und einige in wales die so richtig sauer sind auf wie politik funktioniert in,
in london und dann einfach mal versuchen diese diese diese diese ganze problematik so ignorieren oder so unterdrücken aus meiner sicht ist wird mittelfristig nicht funktionieren man muss,
was am nicht nur an joggern anbieten sondern auch an die englische regionen und da sogar auch.
Laber ein problem weil laber in schottland inwiefern ist noch eine label partei in schottland gebt sie ist offiziell.
Gegen die unabhängigkeit aber war auch offiziell pro eu also das bedeutet,
was sind die meinungen die führenden persönlichkeiten als als cobic nachfolge in der labour partei zu dieser regionalen fragen sie haben ja keine,
und die dürfen zurzeit ja keine haare weil die parteimitglieder sind gegen einen unabhängigen schottland,
aber was für ein angebot könnte laber die irgendwie für die schotten vor minimieren.
Die haben ja keine keine antworten gerade.
Das heißt das auf jeden fall auch auszugehen dass die fdp noch ziemlich lange im sattel sitzen wird zumal sie ja auch mit ihrer sozialdemokratisch orientierten politik jetzt
in diesem verdacht geraten jetzt die totalen extremisten zu sein es ist eine eine andere form des nationalismus als den den wir gerade überall sonst ein wenig befürchten,
dann schauen wir doch vielleicht mal auf die auswirkungen der wahl auf.
Nordirland auch da habe ich jetzt gerade die wahlergebnisse nicht so richtig im kopf aber da haben die konservativen jetzt.
So gut abgeschnitten.
Ja also die demo party also die meisten also die starken junior nisten die sind ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen runtergegangen sogar auch haben
auch ein bisschen an stimmen verloren aber an sitzen gewonnen wegen den verrückten wahlsystem und die große die große gewinner in nordirland waren die airlines party also die
unabhängigen die in der mitte sind die eigentlich steht regen und stürzen von von nationalisten sowie minister.
Die hat mir auch letztes mal schon angesprochen dass die halt erstmal sitze im europaparlament bekommen hat und die sind natürlich jetzt los sind.
Genau und die haben ich erinnere mich nicht an dem zahnarzt jetzt zwei oder drei sätzen gekriegt,
aber grob weil bewölkungen mäßig nord-irland relativ klein ist also das,
das spiel ja nicht so eine große rolle in in westminster jetzt also die die hatte eine enorme bedeutung erst die konservativen so schwach waren und äh hat er nur eine schwache regierung unter.
Theresa may und dann in den in den ersten monaten von von boris johnson,
sie haben jetzt an bedeutung dann in politik investments dann deutlich verloren weil die haben.
Die dieses macht so an der grenze zu meiner oma eine mehrheit zu bilden das haben die die die not irischen parteien
jetzt gerade nicht also am ja also es war dann interessant saugt an den grund warum power sharing also den store
tag mal wieder also diese idee dass es kann einfach so weitergehen das alles wird aus london so bestimmt diese so harte kurs der demokratie party also die haben einfach mal.
So ein bisschen zu viel gespielt einfach mal
nicht nur nur die nur die meisten oder eine sehr stark sehr starke fische position vertreten und,
die wähler der waren etwas pragmatischer als die parteiführung das ist dann ein grund warum die dann an an an stimmen verloren haben bei der bei der unterarm.
In dem zusammenhang sind ja auch die wahlen die jetzt vor kurzem in irland in der republik irland stattgefunden haben auch ganz interessant
dort gibt es ja ein hochgradig repräsentatives wahlsystem das sehr lange dauert bis man's ausgezählt hat mit präferenz wahlen allem pipapo,
was wiederum den vorteil hat dass eben wie der name schon so schön sagt die repräsentanz der der abgegebenen stimmen letzten endes im
im parlament.
Ziemlich klar und deutlich ist und also relativ nah dran an den tatsächlich abgegebenen stimmen und dort gibt's ja die interessante situation dass man dort eigentlich so zwei,
mitte rechts parteien hat diese ich zwar in ihren positionen nicht groß unterscheiden aber so rein kulturell miteinander wenig klarkommen weil die sich irgendwann mal gespalten haben und hassen sich
weil sie sich wahrscheinlich lieben eigentlich und die dritte kraft war immer so ein bisschen schön fan und diesmal kam es halt zu einem ergebnis wo im prinzip alle drei parteien mehr oder weniger
auf dieselbe stimmenzahl gekommen ist.
Also vom von der premierminister ist ein bisschen runtergegangen,
feine voll der andere mitte-rechts partei auch sogar einige sitzen,
verloren aber dann ist offiziell als größtes partei die haben eins sitz mehr als die dann auf den zweiten platz,
gelandet sind es gab ja auch einige sitzen gewonnen für die grünen also die haben jetzt mehr als doppelt so viele sitze also ich denke die sind von drei auf über zehn sitzen gegangen,
das bedeutet es gibt jetzt zurzeit große großes unklarheit wie geht alles da dann weiter also die fine viele voll und viele gel wollen soweit ich das verstehe die wollen,
kein koalitionsregierung mit china,
und die wollen auch kein koalitionsregierung miteinander und plus die grünen plus die übrigen labour-abgeordneten ist nicht ausreichend für eine mehrheit so das bedeutet es ist ja sehr schwierig zu sehen
wie wird all das dann ausgehen das ging.
Also brexit spielte da soweit mein verständnis keine riesig große rolle
weil die brexit linie von waren war mehr oder weniger der gleiche wie von von also was bedeutet es war,
kein kernthema des wahlkampfs.
Und das thema war ja eigentlich auch durch also.
Ja obwohl diese es gibt noch diese frage wie sehen die handelshemmnisse zwischen not irland
irland aus nach dem austritt,
britanniens und wir haben auch in den schlagzeilen in den letzten tagen so gesehen ist das alles so klar wie die position der britische regierung in dieser arten von fragen es gibt in den letzten tagen schon die die meine
etwas größer fragezeichen als aus bedachtes also das bedeutet
aber grob weil die positionen der die von weniger die gleichen waren im sachen brexit was bedeutet es spielte dann keine große rolle aber,
wie es dann weitergeht mit die regionsbildung ist zurzeit unklar aber die brexit,
debatte wird dann einfach weiche gehen also es wird kurzfristig kein einfluss haben auf die oder weniger ein versammlung die brexit warte weil das wird zurzeit gespielt zwischen london und brüssel die rolle von von irland ist,
zurzeit weniger wichtig.
Ja aber wofür das natürlich ein signal sein könnte will das gar nicht zu hoch heben ist natürlich die frage wie nah können sich nordirland und die republik irland jetzt noch kommen.
Ja und und natürlich auch solche verhältnisse traditionell für ein vereintes irland obwohl es gibt keine mehrheitliche unterstützung für für diese idee,
in irland und knapp an der grenze in nordirland ja also.
Es ist ja noch schwierig weil die inwiefern.
Ich kann nur ihr land einfach bestimmen wie wird es dann.
Weitergehen ja so das bedeutet wie gut sind die kontakte zwischen.
Die regierung in nordirland und die regierung von boris johnson also inwiefern hat nur irland eine klare position ist nicht so klar was.
Alle auf der irische seite wollen ist unbedingt dass die grenze offen bleibt,
aber wie macht man das also die lösung,
sah anscheinend aus dass man muss export declaration so eine art dokument ausfüllen,
um waren aus nordirland nach den rest von großbritanniens exportieren also das sah dann lösung aus aber dann.
Entweder ich denke war gestern nachmittag boris johnson dann gesagt nee also solche social import controls führen wir in den rest von großbritannien nicht ein,
also das widerspricht was alle abgeschlossen haben in äh im november so das bedeutet dass wir haben so gedacht dass.
Grob diese wir haben so eine lösung gefunden aber jetzt in den letzten tagen gibt's mal wieder unklarheit darüber also,
ja es ist schwierig jetzt mehr zu dem thema zu sagen also nur einfach mal wir dachten dass wir hatten eine lösung aber es ist jetzt nicht mehr so klar.
Ich wollte euch erst mal ein bisschen bei der politischen situation von nordirland bleiben weil über die auswirkungen und der verhandlungen werden wir gleich nochmal sprechen,
es gab ja jetzt auch die situation in nordirland dass diese land also das parlament oder quasi eigentlich gar keine wirkliche regierung gab des karfreitagsabkommens hat ja eigentlich.
Quasi gefordert dass es sozusagen so eine über alle parteigrenzen hinaus oder lager grenzen hinaus eine gemeinsame regierung geben sollte die gab es aber jetzt schon seit einigen jahren nicht mehr,
jetzt ist glaube ich irgendwie eine deadline abgelaufen und kurz vorher haben sie sich jetzt doch mal wieder darauf geeinigt weil sie es eingesehen haben dass sie jetzt einfach mal eine starke position brauchen.
Ja genau und die haben die austrittsabkommen den jetzigen
hallo
ein heilig alle abgeordneten die haben boris johnson tierischen parlament vereint wie nie zuvor also alle abgeordneten waren gegen seine austrittsabkommen alle jede jede jede einzelne also das bedeutet,
und auch ein grund dafür ist.
Die hat bei der unterhaus war so gesehen im moment mal vielleicht war unser kurs nicht der richtige also wir waren zu nah an den konservativen in westminster,
und einige von unserer wähler sind zu den also den parteien so die
etwas pragmatischer juniorenmeister und einige sind auch so gesund in der linse party einfach so so diese diese unabhängige parteien der mitte,
so kann es einfach nicht weitergehen.
Die rolle die die harte theresa may premierministerin war also das haben die jetzt nicht also die haben so power nicht mehr weil die konservativen brauchen die
also einfach mal okay wir brauchen uns so ein bisschen einen richtungswechsel wegen brexit
aber nie schnur sondern auch wegen diese etwas geendet der politische lage in neuseeland die sind dann die gründe warum die sitzen da mal wieder in in in nordirland.
Es ist immer noch unbekannt wie wie wie viel einfluss wird das dann haben auf die zukünftige.
Brexit position von nordirland weil grob oder so weg gedacht haben die nordirland-frage war so schon beantwortet obwohl ich jetzt diese fragezeichnen also hält großbritannien noch am,
was die vorher abgestimmt haben aber so ja also,
sturm und tag wieder aber was für ein einfluss das harnwerte brexit bleibt noch zum teil unbekannt.
Das ist ja nichts neues das ist ja nichts neues ja.
Das also jetzt sozusagen die situation nach den wahlen und.
Nach dem brexit-chaos folgt das nächste brexit-chaos.
Jetzt hat man vor allem erst mal so ein paar wochen gesehen wo boris johnson ein bisschen anklingen lassen welchen stil der regierung er denn jetzt so.
Zu führen pflegt weil jetzt ist er auch so dass auch so ein argument der der remain die natürlich alle total frustriert waren nach dieser wahl
dass sie meint na ja dass das einzig gute was man in dieser situation jetzt abgewinnen kann ist josef also jetzt müssen sozusagen jetzt gibt es keine ausreden mehr eigentlich.
Aber es gibt ja ausreden noch es gibt ja immer ausreden na so und und und ich war immer ein bisschen skeptisch auf diese idee das ja die werden dann einfach mal so irgendwie verantwortlich agieren nein weil,
das ist gegen den ganzen idee von brexit insgesamt also es kam auch,
es war ein bisschen eine nebensache aber in the daily telegraph peace.
Brexit ist nur das erste schritt das nächste schritt ist die komplette eu süßer stören,
also wirklich also lass bitte lass uns doch in ruhe hier in die anderen länder der eu aber das ist so ein bisschen die die die diese
gedanke weil viele haben sie gedacht ok
brexit die haben das jetzt geschafft jetzt wird so eine neue pragmatismus geschaffen werden innerhalb der regierung viele sehr bekannte journalisten darunter john simpson der sehr bekannte baby und das haben sie ja so
im herzen boris johnson pragmatisch also wird dann pragmatische lösungen dann finden nein also die haben das bis jetzt nicht,
nicht gemacht nicht getan und grob also boris johnson die leute die um boris johnson sind die sind ja keine pragmatismus und man sieht auch grob,
wenn man versucht pragmatische lösungen für diese brexit situation zu finden.
Dann man stirbt man die frage also ja wollen wir das überhaupt dann durchführen.
So das ist was wir dann gesehen haben in diese periode nach der,
nach der auswahl also es gab so erst ein bisschen so ein bisschen ruhe diese abstimmung in dem britischen unterhaus kriegen wir alles dann bis zum einunddreißigsten durch um um überhaupt dann auszutreten das haben die dann hingekriegt.
Dieses austritt gesetz in den britischen unterhaus also es gab einige sehr wichtige änderungen auf der britische seite weil das britische parlament.
Hat sich jetzt aus dem prozedere ausgeschlossen vorher war es vorgesehen dass das was für ein abkommen.
Ende dieser also wir sind,
die haben jetzt den austrittsabkommen es wird auf offiziell bis ende zwanzig zwanzig den abkommen zu die zukünftige beziehung,
wird's ja geben und offiziell muss es da dann eine abstimmung des britischen unterhauses geben am ende diese prozedere das war vorgesehen vor der unterhaus wahl.
Dann kam der fall und dann diese variante des gesetzes was boris johnson dann reingebracht hatte mal wieder anfang januar an dem britischen unterhaus,
hat dann keine rolle mehr des britischen unterhauses dann vorgesehen einfach mal keine abstimmung am ende wenn du das britische unterhaus sagt nee moment mal also dieses dieses dieses,
abkommen zu den zukünftigen beziehungen mögen wir nicht.
Dann pech ja also die haben dieses anmacht dann in die regierung einfach abgeben also das ist so eine entkernung des des,
parlamentarischen kontrolle also dass die bereit sind sowas zu machen und das ist eine enorme macht gewinn für boris johnson und die regierung,
und dann haben wir dann in den in den letzten paar wochen einige so beispiele so so gehört oder die ersten ideen der britische regierung
besonders es gab in granit von london am dritten februar eine rede von boris johnson und dann am siebzehnten februar
eine rede an der universität brussels von der der chef und der verhandlung von von die britische regierung david frost
so haben wir dann ein bisschen eine idee von was wollen die briten hier einfach dann.
Machen und grob zusammengefasst es ist folgendes es gab dieses logan take back control also wie den sinn von brexit,
ist die kontrolle von brüssel so so zu gewinnen.
Damit wir unsere eigene zukunft in unsere eigene hände haben damit wir unsere eigene politik in diverse themenfelder setzen können.
Und jetzt wenn man man hört diese rede von johnson oder oder sogar von frost.
Also dieses gewürze gewinnen an macht ist nicht den weg so eine ende.
Sondern wie manche sagen es sind ende also es ist eine ende in sich selbst kann man sagen auf deutsch.
Na ja so eine ich suche gerade noch nach einem guten nach einer guten übersetzung erkläre erstmal ich.
Go go frost sagt.
Den sinn von brexit war einfach mal dieses macht zurückzuerobern nicht dass wir oben dieses macht zurück um was zu ändern an faktisch ist zu theoretischer.
Ein selbstzweck.
So selbstzweck ist so eine selbstzweck geworden und das ist dann ein unsinn also das bedeutet ja wir haben kontrolle irgendwie so gewonnen aber wofür.
Und wenn man mal schaut in diese rede von von von boris johnson ist es einfach ja also wir wollen nicht geringeren standards in der agrar- industrie setzen,
warum sogar hören standard aber wir wollen einfach nicht dass brüssel und sagt.
Was sind dann einfach die die standards die wir dann respektieren mussten.
Einfach mal ja wir sind nicht böse aber wir wollen nicht alles juristisch regeln.
Ja aber gleichzeitig wir wollen die komplette kontrolle für unsere fischereipolitik gewinnen obwohl britischen fischerei boote haben die ganze fangquoten an anderen länder der eu sogar verkauft.
Ok wie funktioniert all das denn so was bedeutet dass.
Dieses idee ist einfach mal eine theoretische macht gewinn ist dann.
Das rhetorik von die britische regierung wir wollen die kontrolle übernehmen aber wir wissen nicht wofür ja also.
Das ist ja dann aus meiner sicht ein unsinn.
Aber dann wenn man stellt die verhandler dann genauere fragen es ist weil die wissen ja nicht was.
So ein sorten eroberung der macht unbedingt dann bedeutet wir nehmen hier dann einige beispiele.
Datenschutz zuerst also es gibt den datenschutzgrundverordnung für die ganze eu es auch,
in kraft in großbritannien natürlich
also ich war einige treffen in in in in london vor ein paar wochen ich hab dann die frage gestellt also wie regelt dann großbritannien
diese situation also wird großbritannien den datenschutzgrundverordnung noch implementieren nach dem austritt.
Es ist ja sehr wichtig politisch gesehen dass wir unsere eigene datenschutz politik haben habe ich von den behörden gehört.
Ja so was bedeutet das dann also wird es wie geregelt wie mit dem vereinigten staaten und da gab's ja keine keine antworten.
Da bist du dann gefragt wie hoch können dann die kosten sein ist und wo ist die grenze.
Wie viele britische tech-unternehmen müssen dann schließen.
Damit dass die kosten so hoch sind einfach mal wo ist den punkt wo die britische regierung so geht nach und sagt ok.
Hier müssen wir die eu normen respektieren weil die kosten sind einfach so hoch etwas anderes zu machen.
Das ist genau wie die schweiz agiert im den ganzen bereich der lebensmittelsicherheit.
Die implementieren die ganze eu-regelungen in sachen lebensmittel gesichert weil es einfach so teuer ist für die schweizer produzenten.
Schokolade für die eu maße produzieren und das für den schweizer markt zu anderen standards,
schweizer ok in sachen lebensmittel sie scheint es und es ist uns einfach so teuer wir geben dieses macht dann einfach ab weil sie uns zu teuer ist.
Ohne im bereich der.
Wenn man wenn man aufs auto firma ein neues modell auf den markt bringen will ja diese diese zulassungsbezieher.
Wie großbritannien eine neue zulassung einführen dass man braucht eine separate zulassung für großbritannien und dann eine zulassung für andere länder der eu
und wenn man produziert das auto so ein mini oder ein nissan zum beispiel die die die fertiggestellt sind in großbritannien braucht man dann,
dann irgendwo von woanders dann die zulassung wie hoch sind die kosten wie viel auto verbringen in großbritannien mussten dann geschlossen werden,
damit es sich.
Überhaupt lohnt dieses idee und ich hab so dann gedacht um moment mal so irgendwann mal die briten werden dann im punkt erreichen die werden dann überlegen ok.
Ja vielleicht sind die kosten in sachen datenschutz so hoch da respektieren die eu normen und im bereich der zulassung für autos ja okay unser eigenen standards die kostet sie nicht so hoch.
Weiß ich nicht aber irgendwo da muss ja eine grenze geben ja gut wann die kosten einfach so hoch sind das ist nicht wie die briten gerade agieren,
die sagen nein wir wollen dieses macht so gewinnen und wenn die eu seite.
Das uns nicht gibt was wir ja wollen da ist dann die eu seite dann schuld punkt und.
Dann meine quellen in großbritannien also ich habe dann gesagt also niemand in anderen ländern eu der eu werden dann mal glauben,
dass die eu da shot wäre für alle werden auch nie das ist weil die briten waren zu verrückt denn wie wie wie die da verhandelt haben also,
aber das macht die britische autoindustrie dann kaputt,
ja also wir auf der europäischen seite sind sind nicht da schon niemand in deutschland und fallen kann ich werde da mal sagen ja also michael barnie hat das kandal getan ist so das ist weil die briten haben so einfach mal falsch verhandelt.
Ja aber,
herr sie müssen verstehen das ist unsere linie also wir verhandeln weil wir wollen macht so herr orban ja also wir wussten nicht wie hoch die kosten sind und wo dann wo wo wir dann einen punkt erreichen dass wir geben einfach nach.
Und dann man baut schonend dieses rhetorik in großbritannien auf ja so wenn alle scheitert das ist weil die eu nicht flexibel genug.
Ich kriege dann den eindruck dass großbritannien hat da einfach mal wieder wenig gelernt weil.
Es gibt aus meiner sicht jetzt drei möglichen optionen auf den tisch entweder.
Großbritannien tut alles was die eu wählen kriegt dann ein gut einen deal.
Wo man hat antworten auf fast alle fragen bis ende des jahres schon.
Für die schweiz so.
Ja aber einfach mal das.
Bestimmt von der eu aber es regelt die meisten so industrie.
Felder ja sagen wir schauen es uns in see gering weil großbritannien lehnt das ab.
Die zweite option option ist großbritannien kriegt was bis ende des jahres aber da drin gibt es viele unklarheiten und die beiden sind nette blieben so eine.
Permanente ausschuss für die weiteren verhandlungen,
so was wäre möglich vielleicht oder die dritte option ist großbritannien steuert auf ein no deal kurs bis ende des jahres will keine verlängerung,
und sagt sorry also wir akzeptieren nicht was die was die die börse eu sagt wir gehen dann ohne deal raus.
Das ist im weg wo auf die briten gerade steuern die die hoffen dass die eu.
Geht nach aber die eu an zwei gründen nicht nachzugeben erstens die eu ist die stärkere partner hier und das haben die briten nicht verstanden,
es gibt ja noch die option schon vorgesehen in den austrittsvertrag das wir haben wir zeit,
also warum verwenden wir dann diese zusätze seid einfach nicht liebe eine gute brexit als unbedingt ein brexit bis ende zwanzig zwanzig so das bedeutet das,
die linie was großbritannien die britische regierung jetzt gerade tut er ist eine komplette schwachsinn aus verhandlungs- sicht,
aus kommunikation sehe ich wie man das die britische bewölkung überzeugt ja wir sind die starken ja wir haben das gute gefühl dass wir wer wir wir sagen die börsen europäer was die dann dann dann dann tun können.
Aber das ding ist auch es gibt kein vertrauen
zur zeit zwischen den beiden seiten oder die die eu-seite vertraut die britische seite überhaupt nicht und besonders diese woche beim,
john cena so gesagt oder johnson so leute um johnson
ja was sind denn in die politische deklaration steht also das ist die nicht bindende teil des des des austritts abkommens.
In sachen not ihr land ja das respektieren wir hall nicht.
Wir führen keine kontrollen ein auf exporten aus nordirland in richtung den rest von großbritannien und das ist.
Das ist wie eine rote fahne für busse,
hey moment mal das haben wir schon verhandelt wir haben versucht ihm einen guten deal anzubieten und jetzt respektiert johnson nicht was wir mit ihm verhandelt haben.
Also was tun die also die wollen die einen deal oder oder doch nicht.
Vor allem das kann ja auch potenzielle also da das hat ja auswirkungen auch weit über das verhältnis der eu hinaus weil ich meine großbritannien wenn sie für irgendwas bekannt waren dann dass sie sich im prinzip an ihre ganzen ausgehandelten verträge auch wirklich,
gut halten dafür war großbritannien besonders bekannt und wenn sie das halt nicht machen ist das ja nicht nur ein signal an die eu das ist ja eine.
Signal an alle länder andere länder der welt.
Alle länder so nach dem motto ja wir können ja mal irgendwas aushandeln aber wenn's uns das nicht passt halten wir uns einfach nicht dran ganz ganz ganz schlechte idee so.
Und diese idee dass die dieses ruf von großbritannien vollkommen kaputt ist in anderen ende der eu ja also ich habe
ich komme direkt aus der schweiz wo ich dir in den letzten paar tagen gearbeitet habe aber damit
zufälligerweise einige schweizer politologin getroffen moment mal das ist das ist ja doof die kümmern sich nicht um den eigenen ruf.
Aber das bedeutet dass ich ich ich habe so irgendwann mal so gedacht ja großbritannien jetzt,
zumindest die britische regierung hat jetzt zeit und er hat eine stabile mehrheit die haben zeit bis zwanzig vierundzwanzig das ist wann die nächste unter auswahl stattfinden muss enorm viel zeit die haben einen mehrheit von nach sie sitzen.
Die können jetzt zumindest mal sein okay moment mal wir brauchen jetzt einen halbwegs ordentlichen brexit also das wäre.
Möglich durchaus möglich aber die leute rundum johnson das wollen die halt nicht.
Und diese rede von chef unter verhandler frost.
Ich glaube nicht an die schlechten wirtschaftlichen folgen für großbritannien im falle einer not deal du glaubst ja nicht,
was ist das ein religiöses fundamentalismus du bist bitte der chef unter verhandler und dann in den nächsten satz sagt er ja wir wir brauchen eine
war eine bessere politik für wissenschaftlichen recherchen in großbritannien so ja so wir glauben die wirtschaftswissenschaftler überhaupt nicht,
und und dann mit die begründung dass wir brauchen eine eine bessere politik der der der wissenschaftliche recherche es ist so in.
Unsinn und der ist der chefunterhändler also das bedeutet es.
Aus meiner sicht dann die eu muss einfach dann ruhig bleiben und einfach dann warten bis der der lage sich ein bisschen in großbritannien beruhigt aber.
Ich sehe auch irgendwie für für die für die die serie regale brexit-befürworter die fürchten dann das.
So eine wie verhandlungstechnik sagen salami taktik das bedeutet dass wenn wir reden über hundert verschiedene themenfelder
dass die wenn die die die geben nach innen in in
in alle diversen themen filiale datenschutz heute zulassung für autos morgen flug sicherheitsstandards übermorgen ja man erreicht an dem punkt wo man mehr
was haben wir denn hier erreicht also die haben ja verstanden dass die mussten ja versuchen den druck so erhören war sonst,
das ganze brexit austritts prozedere könnte einfach so irgendwo so stecken bleiben,
also das ist dann in grund für diese so erhöhte druck aber wenn man schaut in was die gerade versuchen zu tun es.
Es ist ja ein unsinn die wollen sich nicht mit dieser see wichtigen details überhaupt beschäftigen.
Die neue regierung macht auch nicht unbedingt so den eindruck als ob sie jetzt da totale experten installiert hätten in ihren einzelnen bereichen sind ja gar keine leute da und gerade was auch die verhandlungen betrifft ist,
war ja schon längere zeit klar auf der einen seite hat man die eu die eu gilt internet international,
als als die die härtesten hunde der der trade nico
also keiner keiner verhandelt so krass und ist es gibt nichts schweres als eine ein ein ein handelsabkommen mit der eu abzuschließen das hat die usa schon bemerkt
viele länder kennen das und das ist halt jetzt mit japan geklappt hat und so weiter das ist für die einfach ein großer erfolg auf der anderen seite hat man halt großbritannien,
die eben weil allein schon die letzten fünfundvierzig jahre das verhandeln von handelsverträgen aufgabe der eu war überhaupt gar kein personal
da irgendeine kompetenz oder geradezu auch nur eine erfahrung so etwas durchzuführen und müssen ja jetzt im prinzip nicht nur bis zum ende dieses jahres etwas hinbekommen,
sondern de facto eigentlich ja eher so bis juni oder juli weil dann sind irgendwie die.
Wenn wir haben neuen standards in der der datenschutz firmen brauchen ja zeit dass du implementieren das kann man nicht ändern von einem tag bis den nächsten.
Ja auch die eu will ja diesmal ein bisschen mehr zeit haben um einfach mal auch die sich auf diese realitäten einstellen zu können wird nicht sagen wir handeln das an mal weihnachten aus damit sowie eine woche später gilt so no way.
Aber die aber es ist ja natürlich sehr schwierig gerade in großbritannien das das kommt bei den.
Menschen mischt an ja also das bedeutet dass das wie früchte diese ganze situation ist ist.
Aus meiner sicht nicht so richtig verstanden also ja brexit ist jetzt vorbei nein es ist nicht so wirklich.
Jetzt geht's erst los.
Und irgendwie dass die regierung tut alles um.
Alles möglichst gut zu kommunizieren in großbritannien die versuchen ja nicht all das so einen halbwegs fähigen oder guten endlage.
Führen also man könnte diese ganze problemen einfach so,
ernst nehmen aber das tun sie ja nicht die die verwendung für so blöde sprüche wie ja wir wollen ein deal wie den deal zwischen kanada und die eu.
Aber das reicht nicht also niemand exportiert autos aus kanada nach ein europäisches land es ist einfach zu feiern.
Luftverschmutzung aus kanada erreicht die eu nicht es gibt keine kanadische fischerei boote die in britischen gewässer fische fangen,
also es ist halt anders es gibt keine.
Waren des täglichen bedarfs soll nicht.
Keine energie exporte strom exporte zwischen kanada und,
die eu weil es kein untersee kabel für strom zwischen kanada oder den anderen seite des atlantiks und europa gibt es ist ja.
Im im vibra reiter sein muss es ist einfach anders als ein ein ein deal mit kanada.
Super fand ich auch die diskussion über den sogenannten australia deal.
Ja genau also kein deal das ist eine umbenennung von no deal ja ja.
Australien das muss man wissen einfach eben keinen handelsverträge hat mit der eu so also so gar nicht und natürlich nochmal viel weiter weg ist.
Ja ja aber ohne auch dieses.
Diese ideen diese rede von von boris johnson ja also wir respektieren den europäischen gerichtshof nicht.
Ja und dann wie regeln wir wenn wenn es irgendwann streit gibt,
ja aber glaub uns also wir setzen keine geringeren standard.
Hey also was ist das denn also sorry also moderne handelsbeziehungen sind auf den basis von verträgen geregelt.
Und dann wenn ein eine stadt irgendwas nicht respektiert das kommt vor einem gericht und es ist natürlich kontrovers mit international verdrängen so aber man versucht juristische wege.
Diese möglichen probleme der zukunft zu regeln und großbritannien seid oder boss sagt ja ich bin einfach glaubwürdig großbritannien ist glaubwürdig ja also vertraut die eu.
Ihr müsst uns bitte vertrauen.
Sorry die eu ist nicht so verrückt ja einfach boris johnson zu vertrauen also es ist so fern von der realität und einfach mal.
Ich auch zum teil haben sie getauft okay zumindest wir haben jetzt eine mehrheit wir haben ein austrittsabkommen wir werden.
Ein bisschen mehr pragmatismus kriegen können nein keineswegs.
Sehr schön sind ja auch die einlassung zu zu der mitgliedschaft zum beispiel im europäischen gerichtshof für menschenrechte.
Ja da müsste man ja jetzt auch nicht mehr mitglied sein für sowas mal ganz interessant weil erstmal.
Während der europäische gerichtshof ein organ der eu ist ist der europäische gerichtshof für menschenrechte.
Nicht teil der eu.
Genauso das gehört zum europarat wo irgendwie siebenundvierzig also wo halt auch noch.
Noch drin ist ja ja.
Ist die ganze debatte scheint extrem inkompetent geführt zu werden und das lässt mich vor allem auch so ein bisschen zweifeln,
ob wir es eigentlich noch mit einem stabilen system hier zu tun haben weil es gibt ja noch.
Einige beunruhigende tendenzen generell ist es so wenn ich so in der letzten zeit überhaupt in den letzten jahren.
So hier mit leuten über brexit gesprochen habe die nicht so involviert sind da kam dann schnell so ein.
Lass sie doch gehen das ist doch egal und so sind wir sie los machen sowieso nur ärger aus den augen aus dem sinn dann haben wir dieses problem nicht mehr.
Meine antwort darauf war immer ja naja das kann man natürlich machen nur kann halt sein dass das problem danach noch viel größer ist.
Weil was ist denn wenn dieses land sich politisch auch nicht mehr stabilisieren lässt wenn sozusagen diese ganzen verwerfungen die jetzt durch den brexit ausgerufen werden ich meine klar kann man sagen na ja dann dann dann dann geht da ein bisschen was pleite da haben sie mehr arbeitslose,
ja gut das haben andere länder auch aber es könnte ja auch durchaus ein punkt erreichen indem es dem land wirklich sehr sehr schlecht geht und dann ist es halt nicht.
Slowenien oder irgendwie.
Oder ungarn.
Oder irgend so ein kleinerer staat der ist irgendwie
keine große power sondern wir reden hier von einer atommacht wir reden hier von einem diplomatischen macht einem land was extrem enge verbindungen zu den usa hat was halt industriell jetzt vielleicht geschwächt ist aber trotzdem irgendwie immer noch ein powerhouse ist was in einem extrem komplizierten internationalen
netz mit dem kommen wels steckt was irgendwie über seine königshaus,
bemerkenswerte verbindung zu sehr vielen ländern hat was auch noch diverse.
Ländereien weltweit überseegebiete hat also die auswirkungen davon sind einfach,
extrem weitläufig und vor allem was ist wenn so eine destabilisierung dazu führt dass ich diese regierung noch weiter radikalisiert.
Und es gab ja jetzt auch schon erste avancen,
so zu äußerungen mit man müsste ja mal das mit dem supreme court neu regeln in großbritannien also im prinzip eine direkte attacke auch auf die kontrolle der regierung,
das hat er wohl nicht gefallen dass der jetzt im brexit vorlauf auch noch,
entscheidung gefällt hat also wir waren ja vor allem zwei entscheidungen erstens dass das parlament muss befragt werden und dann eben nochmal diese rücknahme dieser provokation da hatten wir auch schon drüber gesprochen das war ja auch signal,
also entscheidung mit signalwirkung und jetzt macht es so ein bisschen so den eindruck als geht man halt full full und trump und sagt so.
Das stört uns aber jetzt jetzt ändern wir halt einfach mal die regeln weil wir wollen jetzt hier mal so durchregieren
wohin das führen kann ist natürlich klar man hat so ein neurotisches land was ich in so einem
nationalistischen rausch befindet dann nicht das bekommt was es denkt was ihm zusteht
der feind sind immer die anderen und dann hast du halt irgendwann so eine insel die einfach überhaupt nicht mehr unter kontrolle ist
wo es dann vielleicht entsprechende rights gibt weil die leute dann merken so oh gott nichts mehr zu fressen supermärkte sind lehrer jobs gibt es auch keine wo ist der brexit votet vor und jetzt ist er nicht da und die regierung sagt immer so in der europa ist schuld europa ist schuld
und dann hat man natürlich dann auch irgendwann mal konflikte auf einer ganz anderen ebene dass das was mich so ein bisschen beunruhigt wie siehst du das.
Ja zum teil es gibt auch andere problematischen beispiele also es gibt schon die diskussion,
die finanzierung der bibi komplett zu ende und das auf eine subskription bases also statt das ist pflicht ist in den fernsehbeitrag in großbritannien bezahlen,
oh des vereins der der finanzminister als vor vor kurzem zurückgetreten also vor ein paar wochen.
Mit der begründung des boris johnson wollte ihm sagen okay deine du kriegst deine eigene plättchen weiß es nicht mehr ich als premierminister kann bestimmen was für advisor du kriegst als als als finanzminister,
und die wollten auch den sogenannten office responsibility abschaffen also das ist ein gremium die veröffentlichen unabhängigen,
statistiken über den finanziellen lage des landes also was bedeutet es dass die zahlen wo auf einen zukünftigen haushalt basiert sind sind zumindest unabhängig ja also das bedeutet dass die regierung kann diese zahl nicht.
Fälschen oder oder verschönen.
Und das war ja auch vor dem brexit oft eine instanz die immer wieder nachgerechnet hat gesagt hat so und so sieht es aus.
Und und dann der der,
pro brexit und unrecht konservativer finanzminister java hat gesagt nein sorry sorry bedingungen kann ich nicht arbeiten also ich trete dann liebe zurück.
Also das war schon ein ein versuch die enorme macht zu übernehmen,
es gab auch diese diese situation als es gab so ein ten downing street press briefing.
Und street hat versucht einfach mal so sein okay dies ist journalist lassen wir rein und diese von einer anderen zeitung nicht also john crazy guardian das auch ausgeschlossen,
alle journalisten haben gesagt nee nee das geht nicht also wir gehen alle raus
und war das erste mal dass die ganze so sogenannten lobby journalisten also die die dann über über westminster berichten haben alle gemeinsam gesagt ok so geht es halt nicht also wir als journalisten wir stehen hier gemeinsam gegenüber der regierung.
Aber das bedeutet also wenn die regierung versucht einfach mal zu sagen okay wir geben informationen nur an die freundlichen journalisten und wir geben das an anderen nicht also da ist großbritannien auf eine,
sehr so gefährliche schiene.
Trump playbook ich meine genau dasselbe ist dort passiert diese whitehouse konferenz es gibt es einfach gar nicht mehr und.
Und
johnson macht diese facebook-runde cast statt an einer journalistischen interviews teilzunehmen johnson tauchen nicht auf als es die überschwemmungen gab vor ein paar wochen in großbritannien der war nirgendwo zu sehen weil wenn er taucht auf irgendwo in irgendeinem staat irgendwo der wird bestimmt,
angeschrien war selbst,
wenn es irgend eine krise gibt das ist selbst nicht so besonders populär so das bedeutet ich sehe ja dieses gefahr ist ja ernst also ist
man könnte es doch noch retten wenn wenn label bildet eine gute opposition wenn die konservativen sehen dass die verlieren an sitze wenn es lokalen wahlen gibt es gibt in den ok london wird sowieso laber wählen ja aber es gibt in londoner,
bürgermeisterwahl jetzt anfang mai.
Rob stewart antritt.
Andre hatten nur chance also wird einfach gewinnen der das nicht der alle überragend ste bürgermeister aber,
verloren es geht ja also der sagt den richtigen dingen verfüllung also das bedeutet dass man sieht da einen weg dass großbritannien.
Könnte einfach mal sein ok also mit einem besseren parlamentarische opposition dass die journalisten arbeiten zusammen um einfach dann,
diese kontrolle kontrolle funktion zu behalten dass das britische unterhaus,
kämpft gegen diese diese entwicklungen ist gegen die die abschaffung von den fernsehbeitrag,
gegen änderungen von dem stream zum beispiel so man könnte so ein weg sehen dass es könnte doch noch in ordnung sein oder man sieht den weg dass es,
es wird einfach noch schlimmer also die halbwegs pragmatische leute wie wenn aus der konservative partei,
ausgeschlossen dass das die nacheinander brexit das ist es
gehe großbritannien so schlecht dass sie brauchen notfall regelungen für die lieferung von.
Lebensmitteln zu sorgen zum beispiel also es gab schon die debatte wenn es wie soll man auf deutsch.
Aufstände.
Wieder aufstellen müssen aufstände gibt kann man diese diese regelungen für so sonderregelungen für die polizei die vorgesehen sind für,
so terroristische anschläge könnte man die dann verwenden um saddam für ruhe innerhalb der bevölkerung zu sorgen also jetzt gab's schon die diskussionen darüber,
aber immer eine stunde ist dass das passt zu den britischen selbstbild nicht.
Wir sind ehrliche menschen.
Solche arten von dingen einschränkungen in via abhängig die die richter sind oder druck auf den babys oder das ist etwas für das boden also das ist etwas für,
nicht funktionsfähigen oder halbwegs funktionsfähigen demokratien.
Der bekannte journalisten aus der herausgeber vom speck tasers oder so so eine konservative partei nahe focus artige blatt.
Der sagt ja dieses rechtspopulismus das ist etwas nur was es in anderen europäischen ländern gibt das haben wir in großbritannien nicht.
Wir schauen da schau mal nach brexit partei was nun drei oder vier prozent gekriegt schauen wir mal deutschland die sind ja die börsen also die kriegen die filme afd kriegt da fünfzehn prozent nein,
es ist also die afd wäre an der macht in großbritannien und die briten die lachen über diese situation in thüringen
schau mal was die eigene regierung tut also aber das verstehen die briten nicht ja also weil diese
diese tendenzen sind innerhalb der konservative partei so tief gewürzwelt oder diese diese
der sogenannten report also diese bericht über den einfluss russlands auf den brexit referendum
dieses bericht gibt's ja schon aber die regierung verweigert das zu veröffentlichen weil das das wird dann mal sein dass es gab ja russisches einfluss auf den brexit referendum ja also.
Das britische demokratische system,
ist in eine sehr gefährliche lage so zeit aber die das wird nicht in großbritannien ernsthaft debattiert ja manche die erfahrung haben aus anderen europäischen länder sehen das aber es gibt kein mehrheit der menschen die sehen wie.
Wie schlimm das alles gerade.
Und das ist genau das trifft so ein bisschen meine befürchtung und das macht es natürlich für die eu jetzt auch wieder schwierig weil irgendwie sieht man es ist so ein bisschen wie so ein.
So ein kind was die ganze zeit schreit und sich gegen alles wert so aber man weiß wenn man jetzt mit repression kommt dann macht man alles noch schlimmer ja also.
Ja ja ja ja.
Genau die richtige beschreibung.
Ich sehe richtig die verzweiflung bei den über den unterhändlern die einfach wissen so ja wir haben zwar jetzt eine riesen keule hier eigentlich und damit können wir sie komplett fertig machen aber wenn wir das machen machen wir es unter umständen noch schlimmer
und das das das macht glaube ich die situation einfach so fragil und und so schwierig dazu entscheiden.
Zumindest es wäre aus meiner sicht klug dass die eu muss einfach bis april mai.
Einfach möglichst ruhig bleiben,
schwierig ich weiß die eu will dass die verhandlungen vorankommen aber bleib mal ruhig warte bis es eine funktionsfähige opposition gibt in großbritannien und dann wird die debatte zumindest ein bisschen anders das bedeutet dass.
Irgendwie eine opposition um einfach.
Eine opposition zu wählen also irgendwie das war ein fehler von jeremy corbyn der wollte immer ja wir sind gegen was die regierung tut.
Und das ist was wir machen wollen hat er immer versucht,
so eine vision zu geben nein oh eine gute opposition ist einfach die regierung so unterminieren einfach mal alle mitteln
parlamentarische in den medien einfach gegen vorschläge zu machen mit statistiken mit mit mit mit freedom of information request die offizielle prozedere dorthin und dokumente von der regierung zu kriegen
alle mittel einfach mal das leben für die regierung schwierig zu machen also auf alles,
egal label muss kein unterhaus wahl gewinnen bis zwanzig vierundzwanzig das label braut keine klare brexit position was labern unbedingt machen muss ist,
die schwächen der jetzige regierung zu finden und wenn label beginnt sowas zu machen das mache dann die kommunikationsabteilung auch für die eu etwas einfacher weil dann,
das bedeutet dass die köln irgendwie gleichzeitig die schwächen der regierung zu finden.
Wenn nichts an fürchtet denn den autofabrik in sondern zu schließen wenn die eu sagen moment mal also da gäbe es ja eine lösung ja,
eine gemeinsame system für zulassung von autos und labels auch im moment mal so dass dieses preis für den brexit ist einfach so hoch da brauchen wir eine andere lösung und so eine lösung könnte so und so aussehen
dann wenn die dieses tor kommt von beiden sein so das mache dann diese arbeit für die regierung deutlich schwieriger zurzeit wenn dieses druck nur aus brüssel kommt dass es dann fehler ist es viel einfacher für die britische regierung das alles abzuwehren.
Ich weiß dass es nicht unbedingt zentrum deiner expertise aber ich will das auch nochmal ansprechen und habe da vorhin schon erwähnt so großbritannien findet halt nicht nur
auf der insel von großbritannien statt sondern abgesehen von nordirland gibt's ja auch noch diese ganzen anderen interessanten bereiche über die einfach keiner richtig redet.
Es geht los mit gibraltar wo wo es.
Auf eine extrem absurde situation hinausläuft weil wenn ich das so sehe wird derzeit auch.
In diesen verhandlungen noch nicht mal so richtig über eine lösung über geballter gesprochen und in geballter wo man glaube ich zu achtundneunzig prozent gegen den brexit war fühlt man sich glaube ich mittlerweile komplett hintergangen,
auf der anderen seite ist es auch nicht so dass eine annäherung an spanien dort irgendeine option wäre.
Auch keine option.
Also da geht man lieber wahrscheinlich zurück zu den alten zeiten wo sie irgendwie erstmal nach marokko fahren mussten um irgendwie ordentlich in spanien einreisen zu können als irgendwie da ein fußball platz zu geben aber es ist halt auch ein militär standort also es ist irgendwie extrem schwierig was
damit passiert dann gibt's diese bedrückende situation mit dieser insel angela in der karibik,
ein land was halt naja eben de facto auch in der eu ist.
Kleine insel lebt aber im wesentlichen davon dass sie eine nachbarinsel hat,
die zweigeteilt ist die eine hälfte gehört zur niederlande die andere hälfte gehört zu frankreich
die niederländische seite ist ihnen zugewandt und dort ist vor allem auch der große flughafen wo die touristen flieger landen können wovon die leben und so weiter und der tägliche trade mit diesem,
inselstaat ist einfach überlebenswichtig für dieses land ja also was passiert damit und dann natürlich darf man nicht vergessen die falk land.
Inseln weit im süden,
die halt eigentlich davon leben dass sie ihren fisch den sie da fangen nach argentinien.
Verschiffen und dort verkaufen können weil es eben ein handelsabkommen der eu mit argentinien gibt all das fällt halt irgendwie weg.
Und dürfte alles krisen machen ist nicht so lange her da hat großbritannien kriegsschiffe zu den inseln geschickt weil argentinien da eingeritten ist die argentinier sind immer noch extrem schlecht zu sprechen auf dieses,
thema sicherlich nicht richtig was argentinien dort tut weil irgendwo kann man diese inseln auch einfach mal,
ist eigentlich auch egal aber wir wissen wie das eben so ist wenn es irgendwie ein feind gibt dann stürzt man sich drauf damit kann man dann schön von eigenen problemen ablenken.
Ich weiß nicht wie wie dieses system künftig weiterleben soll.
Niemand aus meiner sicht zu regierungskreisen in großbritannien hat.
Gute lösung für alle diese problematischen situationen vorgeschlagen.
Es ist also auch nur die irland ja wo fast eine million menschen leben und einfach sehr engen verbindungen mit den rest von großbritannien hat.
Dass auch nur die landes für die britische regierung relativ egal.
Also inseln die tausende kilometer sind von großbritannien oder gibraltar auch ein paar tausend kilometer von von von london.
Das spielt zurzeit keine rolle null roller in die in die debatte also man könnte alle diese probleme lösen,
aber um ein problem zu lösen muss man zuerst dieses problem ernst nehmen und akzeptieren dass es ein problem ist und man nimmt das dann rein als teil der verhandlungen.
Und dann man muss dann einfach klar und ehrlich kommunizieren einfach mal so sagen ok die gebraute.
Ist für uns wichtig und das ist unser ziel ist sowas für gebraute dann zu verhandeln.
Das spiel diese ob diese diese drei beispiele die du da korrekt benannt hast die spielen in die debatte die öffentliche debatte zur zeit überhaupt keine rolle.
Also und wie ist das gefühl für für für menschen aus dieser insel und ich denke es gibt leute die auf den vogel inseln leben also,
wie können die dann druck auf großbritannien.
Dann ausüben also wenn es nicht zu einem krieg führt wenn die verlieren an.
Fisch fangrechte oder die option die diese fische nach argentinien zu so exportieren.
Wie haben die dann ein weg druck auf die britische regierung ausüben haben die da ja nicht.
Dreitausend einwohner plus tausendsiebenhundert.
Soldaten okay gut.
Soweit war ich dann nicht aber ich wusste nicht was für eine anzahl an der soldaten also haben wir ehrlich gesagt irgendwie wenn man.
Wenn man vertreibt eine politik nur für.
Offiziell für die zweiundfünfzig prozent die dann für den austritt gestimmt haben und man definiert seine ganze politische ziele.
Nur dem genau deswegen ja das bedeutet dass.
Meine interesse wenn ich verliere mein job oder ich vielleicht kann ich.
Nicht mehr in dem ort sogar leben wo ich grade lebe oder diese andere einflüsse.
Die dann wichtig sind oder oder wichtig sein sollen um eine politische entscheidung zu treffen.
Die britische regierung anführt einfach mal ja sorry also pech oder oder antwortet antwortet einfach nicht,
weil wenn man dann denkt ok
wir müssen was für die autobauer machen wir müssen maß für fisch fange in den inseln machen wir mussten etwas für die.
Ganze online-wetten industrie was gerade in in in geballter so ein großes arbeitgeber ist wenn man sieht.
Diese diversen interessen von diversen gruppen man erreicht an einen punkt moment mal also ist es nicht dass dieses diese man verwendet diese klassische populistische kommunikation.
Ein mehrheit des volkes hat für den austritt gestimmt also nur dieses mehrheit hat recht.
Und alles andere ist nicht wichtig ist und das ist die argumentation von die britische regierung und es ist natürlich.
Eine moderne moderne demokratie ist ja schwierig also das ist wir haben alle differenzierten
interessen inwiefern sind unsere wirtschaftlichen interessen unserer menschenrechts in hessen unsere interessen in sachen einwanderung wenn ich mit jemandem aus einer nische europäisches land verheiratet binnen wohne in großbritannien,
wir haben eine andere interesse aus jemandem der dieses problem nicht hat.
Und man braucht dann ein so eine holistische debatte um um alle diese diversen tendenzen suchen zu verstehen.
Das ist genau was die brexit-befürworter nicht wollen.
Weil um die interessen von den völkern inseln zu verstehen das bedeutet die haben eine besonderheit.
Und das wenn man beginnt diese besonderheiten zu respektieren so akzeptieren dann erreicht man relativ schnell den punkt warum machen wir dieses ding überhaupt.
Und das ist dann den kern irgendwie und dann denkt man da daran und irgendwann mal das.
Wenn es die vogtland insel in fünf jahren wird schaffe ich schlecht geht dann werden die briten dann mal vielleicht ein überlegen hier moment was vielleicht eine schlechte entscheidung brexit so auszuführen.
Es gibt ja noch noch noch ein paar noch eine inselgruppe die ein großes problem signalisieren könnte die auch zu übersehgebiet gehören sind nämlich die cayman islands dir.
Die channel gehören aus.
Wollte ich gerade.
Oh
Genau weil großbritannien war ja immer so ein bisschen auch ein stachel im fleisch weil eben so eine große zahl von so steueroasen und sonderregelungen geht ne also und so weiter wie heißt die anderen beiden noch gönnen sie und.
Jersey jaja.
Jersey genau die waren schon immer sehr problematisch weil aber eben nicht okay in der eu war,
gab es immer so ein bisschen so ein na ja so nicht angriffs pakt in gewisser hinsicht ne man hat sie so ein bisschen ziehen lassen kaum war aus der eu offiziell ausgetreten sind die cayman islands schon mal auf dieser schwarzen liste,
nicht kooperativer länder gelandet und es ist so ein bisschen davon auszugehen dass dort vielleicht auch i love mann und diese ganzen anderen orte wo glaube ich auch eine ganze menge europäer in den letzten jahrzehnten so kleine limited
gegründet haben et cetera dass die demnächst auch unter druck kommen könnte.
Da ist die die situation vielleicht ein bisschen anders weil es gibt ja genug.
Abgeordneten der konservativen partei die auch von diese steueroasen profitiert haben dass die interesse diese inseln zu verteidigen in den brexit-verhandlungen vielleicht ein bisschen höher als ähm
die vogtländerinnen sollen zum beispiel.
Ja ja das heißt aber dass sie mehr kommt dass sie da auch mehr.
Aber man sieht also die niederländer zum beispiel hatten eine interesse ja weil die haben auch.
Netzwerken von steueroasen oder sogar ihr land zum teil auch oder luxemburg.
Es gab ja eine gelände die gleiche interessen haben großbritannien zum teil verteidigt haben großbritannien geholfen haben.
So wird es dann nicht mehr der fall großbritannien wird dann vielleicht nicht die große hoffnung aber muss dann lernen wie geht's dann weiter für diese steueroasen ohne,
nicht die und sage ich dir unterstützung sondern.
Sowie ignorieren die die problemen da schau mal auf mal wie kommen so zum zum datenschutz.
Europäische parlament hatte jahrelang problemen mit den politischen sicherheitsdienste dass die harte immer eins das britische sicherheitsdienste hatte zu viel so backdoors so britischen.
Datenbanken oder tech unternehmen.
Ja großbritannien war in der eu es war immer schwierig das prüfen weil einfach mal wie die eu die die sicherheitsdienste voneinander eins von den einigen mitgliedsstaaten dann prüfen,
jetzt ja klar.
Also dann das bedeutet um equipment zu kriegen in den datenschutzgrundverordnung ja dass das europäische parlament schon gesagt ok jetzt haben wir probleme mit dem britischen sicherheitsbehörden,
hat niemanden gesagt in den letzten paar jahrzehnten also ja großbritannien muss dann mal lernen also ja vielleicht außerhalb der eu hat man weniger alliierten,
es ist nicht dass die für diese diese ganze channel und so dass der situation bleibt genau umgeändert
die war nicht in der eu dieser channel auch ja die die sind in europa aber gehöre nicht zur eu
geballter schon weil die gebrannt hat einen anderen status gegenüber großbritannien also und die haben bei der brexit referendum marvel gestehen dabei.
Die jersey gehören,
also sie sind sicherheit in sicherheitsmäßig geschützt von großbritannien aber sind kein teil von großbritannien
und deswegen waren nicht in der eu die die wählen nicht bei bei britischen unterhaus wahlen die wählen nicht bei bei europawahlen aber gebraute,
europawahlen schon also die haben das wort die hatten schon eine weile lang eine etwas feinere beziehung
aber wenn ich vertrete von dieseln diese inseln wäre würde ich so vor sein büro in brüssel öffnen um um da lobbyarbeit macht gibraltar hat genau das getan
in so einer repräsentatives büro auf den square enix geöffnet also ein schönes nettes büro darm um um um seine interessen gegenüber die eu-institutionen zu beteiligen,
aber die situation wird sich ändern für die für die sind.
Vielleicht zum abschluss nochmal einen blick auf die medien landschaft die ist ja ohnehin ziemlich schwierig in große,
und die auseinandersetzung um die bibel haben wir ja auch schon anklingen lassen das also jetzt hier das öffentliche fernseher oder öffentliche rundfunk auch offensichtlich ins schwitzen kommen könnte aber jetzt ist ja generell die.
Problematik immer gewesen dass es eben,
nicht nur von der von robert nürnberg doch gesessenen zeitungen einfach auch generell von der gesamten konservativen zeitungs landschaft so telegraph und so weiter
ist immer irgendwie so ein latente unterstützung gab für diesen nationalistischen kurs,
ich frage mich ob sich das jetzt in gewisser hinsicht noch ändern könnte und wie die schwierigkeiten die wir jetzt hier schon skizziert haben überhaupt
wahrgenommen werden.
Gibt's da irgendeine hoffnung dass dieser medien zirkus das ganze positiv begleiten kann und das sind auch immer alle noch im waren.
Da habe ich.
Fast keine änderungen gesehen also daily telegraph vollkommen auf diesem kompletten pro brexit kurs mail express sogar auch.
Man sieht in time zum beispiel auch wo es zum mörder gehört.
Da ist es nicht so radikal und die die haben noch so ein verständnis von wem.
Wie könnte so ein rechtsstaat funktionieren also die haben einige gute journalisten die dann all das dann.
Tief recherchieren.
Natürlich independent hund und guardian die sind sowieso gegen die regierung also das bedeutet der situation ändert sich da da eigentlich nicht.
Die große frage ist.
Wie geht es bei den bh dann weiter also es gibt diese große kontroverse die haben so eine eine echt total rassistische frau auf auf babys question time eingeladen letzte woche also es gab eine ein großes kontrovers darüber.
Es gab auch mal wieder eine diskussion zu dieser sehr bekannte moderator von der babys das,
so getweetet ja so
journalisten die dann britische zeitungen in brüssel berichten die verstehen dieses spiel nicht also es ist ja klar dass großbritannien wird diese diese verhandlungen gut durchführen und wird sich durchsetzen.
So und die und die journalisten in brüssel darunter der brüssel korrespondenten von also wir berichten was wir hier hören also wir machen keine auswertung von,
wer wie wer wir wollen dieses diese verhandlungen zu gewinne sondern.
Wie ist die ausgangslage und sorry ja so ist es nicht das weil ich aus busse berichte dass ich alles unterstütze was die eu tut und dass so ein bekannter moderator sagt einfach ja großbritannien wird dieses.
Verhandlung sowieso gewinnen einfach das zeigt dass er hat keine neutrale position.
Die berichterstattung einfach mal ja mach mal eine eine auswertung von wie es aussieht und verstehe mal,
wie es auf beiden seiten aussieht also diese die die qualität der berichterstattung bei b,
ist nicht besser geworden und bibi steht unter enormen druck auch wegen diesem mögliche reform der der der finanzierung.
Zumindest ein positives zeichen die sehr geherrscht zumindest von linken gehasst.
Herausgeberin oder radio produzentin von the day of radio for.
Ist zumindest zurückgetreten also sie sie sie war beschrieben als sehr konservative partei nahe und es zumindest,
zurückgetreten also da hat man vielleicht die hoffnung dass die bekannteste,
radiosendung für politisch interessierten menschen bei der bbc könnte vielleicht mal wieder an bedeutung ein bisschen gewinnen.
So da geht's vielleicht ein kleines bisschen hoffnung aber große änderungen in den britischen medienlandschaft habe ich in den letzten zeit nicht gesehen und und da aus meiner sicht eine hoffnung.
Da gibt es ja nicht es gab die b stand immer immer unter druck ja sie haben sie haben so viel,
zu europäisch berichtet kommt immer die diese dieses kritik von konservativen kreisen es gab vor kurzem eine studie der university of brian großbritannien haben sowieso.
Alle alle berichterstattung ausgewertet und es war statisch vollkommenen nicht der fall also es gab mehr pro brexit.
Meinungen und stimmen aufwärmen den wahlkampf als es pro-europäischen meinung gar bei b aber es kommt immer wieder von konservativen ähm abgeordneten dieses kritik ja die sind einfach,
zu elitär und einfach dann zu pro-europäisch also die dieses kritik gegenüber geht nicht weg also leider der dem.
Also die die britische medienlandschaft ist so so sehr kämpferisch aber.
Von einem hohen qualität ja da habe ich da habe ich noch noch noch wieso vor vielleicht.
Was denkst du wann haben wir so den nächsten showdown.
Mich ständig denke wir werden wenige lösungen haben vor dem sommer.
Ist meine first.
Das label wird einen neuen parteivorsitz kriegen die ersten verhandlungsrunden werden in brüssel stattfinden,
aber ohne fortschritte ohne großes erfolg und man wird dann ein punkt erreichen wo dann die uhr tickt dann mal wieder von beiden seiten sagen hey moment mal also komm hier nicht voran wusste manchmal sagen okay ja so wir können jetzt entscheiden dass.
Wir brauchen mehr zeit und ja also das wäre die pragmatische lösungen in johnson wird dann unter druck sein einfach mal ok es gibt ja in angebot.
Mehr zeit also wann kommen diese verhandlungen voran und es wird dann so ein punkt erreichen wo dann eine opposition zu johnson,
taktiken wird es ja geben,
was gab ja bis jetzt nicht aber das wird ja kommen aber nicht in den nächsten paar nächsten paar monaten aus meine vermutung ist dann.
Frühsommer wird's ja ja geben wenn es wenn es dann mal wieder krachen.
Ja und die wichtigste frage ist natürlich wird es eine neue version des brexit diagramm geben.
Nee nee ich habe ich habe jetzt andere dir,
veröffentlicht ich habe sogar ein diagramm so wer wird parteivorsitzende der der der cdu werden also ich verwende meine diagramme für andere zwecke jetzt
vielleicht wenn wir erreichen so ein ein sehr kontroverses punkt in die verhandlungen ab zurzeit alles ist leider zu wage um einfach zu messen wie wie wie wird's dann dann ausgehen aber vielleicht kann ich es im sommer wenn es wieder so kraft vielleicht veröffentlicht eine neue serie,
aber wir sind im sommer mach ich andere diagramme nicht nicht brexit.
Ja gucken wir mal wie es da läuft dein tipp ist glaube ich dass laschet die den vorsitz gewinnen könnte.
Ja ja ja leider.
Die anderen optionen sind jetzt auch nicht so rosig.
Hier habe ich so ein anderes thema aber aber aber ich finde dass ich habe rücken ein paar mal getroffen und auch in sachen brexit der.
Der ist nicht meine politische ideologie aber der ist als person klug und im sachen brexit und außenpolitik,
der war für ein cdu-politiker politiker aus meiner sicht durchaus gut,
und wie was er gesagt hat und inwiefern er kümmert sich um den details des brexits ich war von ihm positiv beeindruckt ich war in sachen brexit weil bei der der friedrich schmerz war brexit-beauftragter des landes nrw,
was hat er da so in sachen brexit geleistet.
Und laschet keine ahnung aber in sachen brexit also da hat aus meiner sicht ähm röttgen so.
Für ein cdu-politiker zumindest die richten sing dingen gesagt und und und ich habe einen positiven eindruck von ihm aber der der ist der außenseite in diesem.
Absolut john vielen dank.
Herzlichen dank.
Für das update wir beobachten mal die situation wenn sich hier wieder was nennenswertes tut in der zwischenzeit werde ich hier bei ukw mal anschauen welche anderen europäischen katastrophen man hier vielleicht noch mal den fokus nehmen sollte.
Dazu aber dann später mehr ich sage danke.
Dankeschön.
Und ich sage vor allem tschüss und.